et notre invité chez bien half elle a
fait une énorme actualité toute l'année
7 millions de spectateurs devant le losc
devant loft story loana
bonjour moi je suis sidéré par votre
succès j'ai jamais vu autant de gens qui
passaient devant le maquillage ici à
france 3 pour regarder comme ça en dix
ans loana loana comment est ce que vous
vous analysez votre propre succès quel
regard vous avez en fait sur sur cela je
suis juste en fait une personne comme
toutes les autres les gens ont réussi à
se dénicher un mois je pense par le
biais de l'écran sinon c'est tout juste
les ateliers sont les adolescentes
voudrait être un petit peu comme moi ou
voudraient être ma petite amie ma grande
soeur la petite anissa ce que pour un
garçon bien sûr que ça soit peu après
après moi de savoir pourquoi j'ai pas de
réponse ben pourquoi c'est pas sur une
laure sur une julie et pourquoi ça tombe
sur vous qu'est-ce que vous avez c'est
du charisme c'est je sais pas je sais
pas pourquoi moi plus qu'une autre
je pense que les autres aussi ont un
certain succès après ça dépend dans
quelle voie on veut se mettre
mais c'est le mythe de cendrillon en
fait c'est ça cc la petite cendrillon
qui devient une princesse un conscrit
c'est un conte de fées c'est vrai qu'il
ya plein de gens partout c'est sidérant
alors voilà on va parler de ce livre si
mots qui nous met à l'antenne elle
m'appelait miette miettes c'est un petit
surnom que vous donnez votre maman un
petit mot là dessus on connaît un peu
l'histoire de miettes miettes
oui ma mère m'appelle comme ça depuis je
suis toute petite elle m'appelle encore
comme ça donc c'est mon petit surnom
j'ai tout entendu donc ça me rassure et
m un petit mot qui m'a fait que ce que
j'affectionne devant mon livre alors
dans ce livre vous parlez de votre vous
parlez de votre enfance du loft ou
parler de vous de vos petits copains
pour le faire vous avez reçu un million
de francs d'avancé sur recette des
éditions pauvert ce qui est énorme on
vous dit dans le livre que jean françois
kervéan qui est journaliste à france
soir vous a aidé à mettre tout ça en
oeuvre et la première version qui vous a
présenté n'a rien à voir avec celle ci a
été commercialisé qu'est-ce que vous
avez retravaillé ou retouche et surtout
j'ai quasiment toujours travaillé à 80%
c'est moi qui aurais très écrit les
textes tout simplement la base ce que je
voulais écrire mon livre pour écrire
moi-même ma vérité et c'est vrai que
c'est quelqu'un d'autre qu'il faisait ça
aurait pu être lui ou comme n'importe
quel autre
je n'étais pas satisfaite parce que je
s'attarder sur certains trucs que moi
j'aurais enlevé et moi je voulais
décrire plus d'émotion que je ressentais
lui pouvait pas le faire donc j'ai pris
mon mal en patience non en fait j'ai
pris les plats les pages aisée débarré
et derrière j'ai réécrit donc lui tout
ce qui reste à lui en fait c'est tout ce
qui est un peu loin à paris
luan actuelle par contre ce qui concerne
mon passé chez tout réécrit 80 mille
exemplaires vendus ses sorties il ya
combien de temps quinze jours trois
semaines et c'est sorti le 9 9 octobre
c'est un énorme succès vous avez gagné
pas mal de sous déjà avec votre éditeur
un million de francs 1 million et demi
dans le loft vous savez à peu près qu'on
va vous avez gagné depuis que vous êtes
sorti mais voilà ça s'arrête là mais
c'est parce que de temps vous écrivez
qu'en sortie du lot vous avez signé un
contrat d'accord donc vous allez devenir
si en tant que mannequin chez eux mais
on n'a pas de rémunération moi ça dépend
travail qu'on effectue alors en
préparant cette émission tout le monde
disait demande ça loana demande sa loi
n'a alors une question qu'on voulait
qu'on vous demande je vous la posez
c'est est dans le loft
vous vous acharnez sur l'or dans dans le
livre alors ouais souvent sont
aujourd'hui vos relations avec l'or mais
quand même nom mais l'épaisse allait
accepter le fait qu'en fait la critique
beaucoup les personnes sont vraiment
leur parler franchement moi je
privilégie plutôt le contact est plutôt
dire quand je pense que je pense donc
c'est un petit peu ça où j'ai pas trop
apprécié mais sinon quand on se croise
on se parle et on n'est pas là en train
de singer ivg une emphase et l'autre ça
sera jamais la grande amitié est jeune
on en est très on a des caractères très
différents on est opposé on peut
discuter mais après je sais pas si ça
peut aller plus loin le temps de me dire
alors ya eu vous avez eu une aventure
avec jean edouard
on apprend dans le livre que vous avez
eu six garçons dans votre vie dont jean
edouard c'était une belle histoire
d'amour en tout cas vous l'avez vécue
comme telle vous auriez aimé gagner la
maison avec lui en sachant tout ce qu'il
a fait non je sais pas je pense parle
christophe était vraiment idéal très
gentille très posé gagner avec lui non
je pense pas revenir lui de passer
quarante jours encore oh non il est
tellement tout temps à droite à gauche
que même en en gagnant la ville a enfin
maman pression à 45 jours il aurait
jamais été là quand vous étiez dans
l'offre à quel moment vous avez compris
que
or ça parlait et que vous étiez devenu
une vraie star à l'intérêt du loft et
jamais et bien un moment quand kenza
vous vous glisser un petit mot en disant
de mot code pour vous faire comprendre
que dehors il y était c'était une des
premières personnes à partir donc en
fait le coadou c'était vous que vous va
bien et ça voulais juste dire le jeu
marche ça voulait pas dire on fait la
une des magazines ou le jeu marche très
très bien ça veut juste dire que les
gens nous regardent et un peu donc ça
nous donnait pas grande un discret mais
moi ça voulait rien dire sûrement c'est
sur l'ensemble du jeu en général oui
alors moi j'ai regardé loft loana mais
c'était malheureusement pas pour vous
c'est pour le psy qui vous accompagnait
le pister quand même un personnage assez
hallucinant qui donnait des explications
fumeuses sont vos relations d'abord
parce que c'était un vrai psy je pense
ouais je pense bien sûr et finalement
comment vous l'avez enfin est ce qui
vous a été utile ce petit dans le loft
parce que quand même enfin ils étaient
autant étonnant ce personnage vraiment
qu'un petit télé web site tele7 rêve je
trouve sympathique après c'est parce
qu'il a dit j'ai pas vu la cassette mais
oui il était utile il était utile quand
quand nous ça allait pas parce qu'en
fait on centre est vraiment nos
problèmes sur nous mêmes
vu qu'on avait pas de nouvelles de
l'extérieur 1 du tout aux références
faisait une montagne pour pas grand
chose
c'est vrai que lui était derrière pour
dire calmez-vous un petit peu qu est-ce
qui va pas mais il nous a jamais assisté
soit à partir soit à rester c'était pas
du tout ça c'est juste savoir un petit
peu l'état général dans quelles en
étaient et juste pouvoir nous rassure un
petit peu alors un petit mot c'est vous
qui écrivent dans le lobe devient un
petit carnet vous écriviez non en fait
le quart mais bon voilà c'est tous les
dimanches on avait droit à vingt minutes
pour taper sur l'ordinateur
ces pages à passer par internet donc
pendant ces 20 minutes la voix lasse les
écrits qui sont là bas et rendez vous
écrivez à celle qui m'a mise au monde
donc votre maman j'espère que tu es fier
de moi ce que j'aime ne m'oubliez pas
trop vite à l'homme de ma vie
garde tes bras ouverts pour que je
puisse venir me de lotir et protège moi
c'est qu'il aime
c'était un hypothétique hommes de ma vie
ça voudrait dire à celui qui sera là
quand je sortirai protège moi qui avais
pas d'homme sur lequel je pensais sinon
j'aurais mis le prénom quelque chose
mais non c'était à l'homme de ma vie
comme je n'ai pas encore rencontré
s'explorer c'est un peu embêté avec les
images
bah oui oui voilà justement je pense pas
que j'aurai tel avec jean-edouard si si
j'avais quelqu'un à l'extérieur
[Musique]